Emma ranu did an advert for HSBC
recently which you may have missed HSBC
rewrote three classic fairy tales their
book's called fairer tales and it shows
that women don't need men at all with
financial attitudes shaped as early as 5
years old the new book challenges
traditional gender stereotypes the new
book called fairy tales princesses doing
it for themselves reimagines Cinderella
Sleeping Beauty and Rapunzel as
successful business women Prince
Charming
successful business women Charming is a
raised as the main character uh Emma
ranu read to them so in the end the
princesses didn't need a prince to save
them they set up their own businesses
saved their money and then spent it very
wisely maybe one day you'll buy a tower
or set up your own shoe business that's
a quote said the tennis player that's
the worst I mean I read Megan markle's
book The
Bench and that's wor
worse that's
worse um wow yeah um what a inspiring
tale fairer Tales um it's so princesses
doing it for themselves have you seen
the um the uh the the South Park episode
of the where um uh Cartman wakes up he
has a a nightmare you told me about this
other lunch yesterday for the people
that haven't seen it Cartman um kman has
has a nightmare it turns out he's he is
a diverse black woman is character is
recast and all of his friends Kenny and
everyone else are diverse female or
transracial characters and then kman
wakes up from the night no and his
mother comes in what is it what is it
are you having another dream where once
again all my all my favorite characters
in in the cartoons have been replaced by
ethnically diverse women and and she
goes it's okay K it's okay uh the the
CEO of Disney isn't hiding under your
bed
hey would you check would you check
would you check Mom okay I checked she's
not there I'm worried that she's going
to come out again replace all my
favorite characters with ethnically
diverse
women I love those guys God they keep
doing it um yeah I mean it's the same
thing with there was a rather
unappealing um young woman who uh uh was
meant to be play well is playing Snow
White and the new Disney Snow White
Rachel Zigler no no no somebody else and
she is is it yeah Rachel Ziggler Zig
well she said uh Prince Charming wasn't
a prince he was a stalker yeah and she
didn't need a prince charming to
discover that she could be the woman she
could be I mean this is like sub Barack
Obama Circa 2007 like the princess is
the person she's been waiting for or
something you your sister's keeper I I
I why don't they invent new tale that's
what I can never understand with that
why don't they just invent new Tales
instead of screwing up every existing
tale that's love make your boring movie
about an inspirational tale of a woman
who wants to start a business and then
does and has some
success I mean okay make that into a
film why do you have to go and ransack
and rape all of pillage all of the the
storehouse of stories that people liked
Brett Cooper's playing Snow White for
daily wire did you see that announcement
what you hav seen this let me tell you
Jeremy boring and Ben Shapiro are doing
their own liveaction remake of Snow
White with Brett
Cooper as Snow White because she's like
West End trained right so she's very
well trained supposedly a very
well-trained actor who can sing
apparently it's like the triple threat
podcast act thing right uh and they
announced it the other week it's going
to be coming out next year God I hope
they'd slay Disney there's a rumor that
Disney has had to re-shoot a ton of
scenes including all of the dwarf scenes
because originally the dwarves weren't
dwarves right they were like a an
multi-racial just group of different
people they were diverse ethnic women it
was the sou thing again uh but
apparently they this is just a rumor but
apparently they've reshot it all of the
scenes with the dwarfs to CGI actual
dwarfs in oh so they've gone full yeah
because I know that there was a there
was a Revolt of the dwarves which is
something you don't hear every day no
there was a Revolt of the dwarves
because of course dwarf Act
who have their Equity cards are annoyed
because there's not many dead jobs yeah
you presumed that there should have at
least been seven yeah AB plus a stunt
actor stunt dwarf stunt one to do all
seven stunts well you could have 14 I
guess it depends how how demanding the
ACT how much Li you want to spread
around the dwarf actor Community but
yeah the point is is is there actually
was apparently Rebellion about this
because like these are some of the few
like dead roles we've got well is this
not the same the people who didn't cast
that is that not the same group of
people that would say we can only have a
gay actor playing a gay man and we can
only have a black actor playing a black
man and we can only have those people
are such I won't use the word uh yeah I
mean again we haven't got time to go the
pace of these people acting is
pretending to be other
people people will be shocked that most
people who play Hamlet are not
themselves members of the Danish royal
family welcome the world of make Bel a
charity shop in Swansea asked people not
to donate sex toys uh barnardo's
customers have been asked to refrain
from donating used and unused marital
aids as they aren't quite the sort of
toys we're looking
for when they say we want like book your
old books your old toys they didn't mean
sex sex toys I think has a perfectly
good policy for a secondhand shop
customers rifling through the secondhand
dildo V
you
don't what have they got in
here is there a dressing room yeah I uh
customers were also reminded the branch
had CCTV so that these items can be
traced back to the original owners oh oh
according to that means that means that
you there's like a a um uh uh what's it
called that thing in Australia the
boomerang that's a boomerang effect your
dildo away then it's back on your
doorstep the next morning God damn it
why can I rid of this thing Over the
Hedge but he keeps Landing in bernados
and then they bring it
back it's a dilder that will never die
yeah yeah thinking about well thank you
for that story that was beautiful well
I've got another one is there is there a
lesson we can take from this oh I think
just be careful where you put your
dildos really is the matter there the
moral of the story yeah yeah never leave
your dildo in bernardos yeah definitely
not in the Bargain Bin in other news
this episode is brought to you by Maui
Nei venison Maui Nei venison brings the
healthiest red meat on the planet direct
to your door not only is it the most
nutrient-dense meat on the planet
they're the only 100% stress-free wild
harvested venison that you can get
here's my super secret hack if you are
sick of buying meat that always goes off
put it in the freezer from Frozen salt
both sides of it put it in an air fryer
for 10 to 12 minutes each side and you
have a perfectly cooked steak from
Frozen that will never go off because
it's going from freezer to mouth in the
space of 25 minutes it's a complete Game
Changer all of the cuts are spectacular
and you can get them Frozen delivered to
your door but their venison sticks are
my favorite while I've been on the road
you can get the healthiest red meat on
the planet delivered directly to your
door and get 20% off by going to the
link in the description below or heading
to Maui venison tocom / modern wisdom
and using the code modern wisdom
checkout that's M aui Nui venison
docomond wisdom and modern wisdom at
checkout thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that clip with Douglas
you will love the 2hour long podcast
episode which you can watch right
here go
on